angry chick music is what it what i
agree right
yeah by the way if i if i'm going to be
violently labeled in one
one dimensionalized i'll take anger they
exactly
love it no aspects that i was saying
like i wouldn't want to change it for
the other one
but it didn't mean that there wasn't
some sort of like
you know balance yeah yeah and that
doesn't mean that you know i also think
those of us who are known for something
like if someone's known
of you know to be an intellectual
there's some shadows in there of
whatever
that opposite is so if if i'm known for
being empowered you can
almost be guaranteed that there's a part
of me that is really disempowered and
terrified
really yeah yeah yeah what was that for
you
i mean every day i'm always nervous i
feel like i'm a sh
i have the temperament of a shaky poodle
in the body of a black stallion you know
what i mean like
it's this combination of visuals i'll
take that i'm empowered you know
but then all i also have to be the first
to say
so so often i'm not feeling very
empowered and
but i'll take it i'll take that flag